[拍手]
はじめまして
体と申します
今日は ng bt のお話をさせていただきます
なぜ lgbt は金利を求めてくる
というかこのテーマでそう主催者からお話をしてもらえ
代が多かった話を受けました
彼らが国税権利を求めて活動しなければならない
その状況があるかと
受け入れられない背景級のは何なの
テーマ教えてほし
選びません
今日は大黒のことも多いんですけれども
ng リンギの活動と言った時に
今 gmail シロウってこういう育ったでしょうか
こちらは毎年ボーディンループと言われている日本の大型連休の時に
いう答弁で渋谷区て枚されている
盟友カレー等
という一大イベントです
連合パレードは
4人チームテールの国内でもっとも大きなイベント等で全国から数万人もの人が集まり
ましてこうした華やかな
カレーとなったりします
ただ私が数年 lgbt の取材を続けていて感じるのは必ずしも米ねぇ通りではない
ということです
美味しい見える形を集めた軽量として有名なもの一つの銅精鉱普段出府
というのがあると言う
日本では同性婚も研修されています
一つ2015年人ポンプ都渋谷区
こちらですけれども
4日号正確ニュースって条例というものを制定しました
防錆婚を認められて追い抜いけれども同政策に畢生の
当院関係にあると同じようなまま状態にあると首止めますという証明書を発行
と言う
もちろん法律的には
こうしたものとみなされないままではあるんですけど
公の存在とゆうゆさん
桜役の存在なぁ
性格で認めたということでつ大きなニュースにより
世間の関心は釣れましたその後凍った都世田谷区
やって
兵庫県宝塚市いっ
昨日県那覇市之木場もう用の制帽
ちなみに日本で同棲共有の賛成というのはどういう状況にあるかというのをご紹介し
ました
写真分の4調査では
こちらのように年来が合わるほど頭成功への賛成率がきっと
というのが現状です20代では74%の人が造成したのさ
断った
犬は24セント今で彫ります
また専門家の調査では
女性よりも男性
若者やにも講演者に拒否感が強いというデータができます
雪舟のエネルギーの形が詰まっていることというのは結婚だけではありません
皆様の lgbt というもの
何を指すか
そもそもご存知でしょうか
ずびあん a バイセクシャルクロスジェンダーをそれぞれ頭無料コプターまま aba
キーですけれども ng
ま
私が誰も好きにやるか
清潔志向
そんなになりん
姫取ろうとせんだーくるのは自分は生まれたときに性別こう自分が5回
を持っている術つ星
ひろくん
という政治
持った
床はマルーン美形なのか質
合えばん
ことによっての値打ちがある
例えば先ほど同性婚でいけば lg 渡したら同棲1
あるんですけれども
リー
パーフェクションは結構咲い思ったら同棲7日に星なのかでも
とコツだっていきます
まず変なのそれでは自分が行きたいと思う背負えランダーとムース
通常の異性今のような形で
して生活をするという方も
だが一方でプロスペンサーというのを
見た目という体において白い偏見を受けているということがあります
またある cdk するのセクシャルマイノリティの中の
一度ですかありません持ったようなをセクター街の ak というのが存在します
例えばあセクションっていうのは試合勘でないという
x というのは男性女性という政治にもどちらでもないぐらい犬
している人の状態のところ写真
持っていることが違うっていうのはたくさんあるんですけれども
いろいろな方と兄に共通するのはやはりをタップもらえないかな
という悩みなんだと思う
といえば lgbt 団体に10日
[音楽]
4種類どっ祭のイベントをやりたいと
手術を貸してみられ
特に日以降でねん
ということっ
施設の管理者は決まってこういうそういう
してるわけじゃない
本当にいいですね
キャベツしているわけじゃない私は差別しているわけではないんだけれど
設定っていうん
差別があるから
自分の説を使われてしまうと
自分の4枚目で見られる積もったんですよ
そういうのが米なんだこんな感じ
lj pt 団体というのはこういうことを書い招集を覚えているところです
活動内の様々なんです
ています
一容疑者に対する
バッテリー
当事者同士で集まりいえば所属
だったり職長の nit に関する調査研究を行った
様々な活動している
一方で私は咲くなるから騎乗をかけました
方法や広げているどうか茄子でー男性
ここで少し意地の内容を読んでいきたいとおもいます
議会とか差別解消と諦めている部分が強いんですよね
総額生中学生のポロロ6偏見や攻撃の積み重ねが
もうオカマ
子供って残酷じゃないですか
そういう体験源力にしてよなくを変えようとする人は npo 活動ところになる
でしょうけど
を使われているか
遺産をそっとございました
米ショー
に撮る気力遠征
どの言葉と間違う気持ちました
行いえら模様
春歌のし2が絶望
られてるにゃとって周りの芸の人たちにも聞いてみたんですけど
普通の人間としたを使ってほしいと思うえっ
結婚できないかツボを解消したいと思うんじゃないんですよね
を見て3埠頭
どうしておいて擦るんですね
阿蘇今までセクシャルマイノリティの取材なとかソフトがあります
誘導性のために
右へに入れて活動というのはごく一部
僕のゲームを染めた目で見ている
お降りを刺されます
そういう人たちは造成パートナーシップ照明
連合パレードの喜んでいないと
差別的だと批判もあると
フジテレビの子もうどこも騒動でせ
妹紅集めること自体が迷惑だ
n 記事を読んだある lgbt 団体を1
会派のゲート召喚上昇 ku 感想を話しました
傷や変形の頃に発動しないからー
いうのを意識だし当院にします
例えば皆さんの高校時代まで思い出してみてください
高速学校の校則に不満はありません
あったとしましょう
その後マンゴーある高速に関して
買い手とシート訴えたんでしょ
はいてほしいという勇者はいたかもしれませんもしかさらうここに集まってくださるか
ターン
そういう勇者だったかもしれない
だけどもう一方で
家1軒なんでしょ
あげられる人もまたたくさんいたんじゃないでしょうか
活動する郵政ビン底というのは実は彼らの仲も僕総数
オープンの日とは
今は活動せずに隠れてい
先ほどの性病科の調査
では ng bt 対する人にから拒否版トレイにもし合う
京都20代は同成功に対する賛成率は高いという風にお話をしましたけれど
実は
3時との人にセクシャルマイルに2が出た場合絵だと思うだろう
という質問に対しては20代でも難くない
例えばん
職場の同僚に
同性愛者の意図場合嫌だと感じる人は27%
これは強大になった場合に40%やばいです
もし自分の子どもだった場合はさらに55%のまで
渇望するということは自分とすぐをおかなし
セキュリティを幸福にするという購入です
身近な人の方がとしたんだ酒井
そういう状況の中で
活動のしようと選ぶ人はやはり少数多くの人はない
最も無駄なっ
を絶望しても不思議はありません
同じ専門家のデータで身近に当事者がいますか
あなたの身近にいますかという質問に対して yes と答えた日本人は14提携幹線
としています
シャルもいない兄は学校の+の中に一人を必ずいると言われている
はによりも存在していますので
これは明らかに少ないするんです
これがどういうことかというと
本当はセクシャルマイノリティなんだけれども差別が強くて書く
人が管理の割合もなるのでもねパッということでしササ持ってください
例えば先ほどの統制パートナーシップ照明
ナメ滝渋谷区
実は
2018年3月までの間に証明書を書くコツしたカップルは28分
オド時期ターンの間に渋谷区内で提出された功労届けのカツ
日本百名城1分
あなたはこのほど多いと思います
どうせパテなシーンについてはもちろん喜びの声の時のたくさん
一方でこうした声もあり
少年のをご覧に行こうこんな
ゲームを求めてくれても
本当
同性のパートナーとを尊厳するために公正証書を作成するということを知りあと3要件
になってますねでお金がかかってしまう
勇小籔の調べたデータとかあっ
昨年の段階で初のシェイプ証明を取得した
タンクの中で2人の年収を合わせて年収400万円以下落下人達っていうのはゼロでし
た
私はまた1100年このピザも勝てました
の幅広いてっに良いポーズ車
ncd p という言葉を
かなり広く大物を使われるようになってました
こんなイメージで使っているのでも復旧の私は知りたくて
メイクアンケートしました
800円のうち約半数がセクシャル前人気です
その他に
小松菜とこういう意見よりん
ng bt と言葉はケア
発動しているだけじゃだけ
そしてのこそも取材している2
こういう発言をつけましたん
この発言ばかりを持てない
活動家が当事者のすべてだと思わないですよ
金利を擁護するために
1回お得審査するために働いているのになぜ設置物
家を見てみました
彼らをカミングアウトしているから隠れていける自分たちの気持ちをわかってね
当社代表どうして彼らを図っているけれども可能素の自分の思いとは違う
一色なんだけれどもちょっと攻撃的な人もありがとうございます
多様性と寛容っていうのを磨いているけれどもそういうのがちょっと反応なんじゃない
だろう
と言ってみてるね
どちらが正しいよ
間違っていけるのではないですよね
朝の夢ですけど
触手のマイティの遊び体を張るみんなだ
同じではなっています
夢ラメの人がいればコンサバティブんだけど
ここにっぽい人もいればと思っ
なのに責任 x ている姉の活動
いただけます
はメディアの部分にペン入れ国内1位になって持って自分の完成し
例えば差別的だと言われていることがある人も
という言葉ですけれどももちろんこれが大嫌いで一つくらいで変わる努力というと
いっぱいいますけれど一方でハッピーがなく
知識のなく使っているだけの人だったら埋めしなきゃよねっていうゲームの方またそう
ですね
ncp っていうのはそもそも社会でどう思っているの関心を持たれているのか
ちょっと気になりました
試しにツイッターで ajt という言葉が来てまで日本のペットの数の推移をし合う
2014年パねえ豚
856マン県でした
1半数は昨年のなくに入った生産性発現いわゆる
と
帰還するものでしたこの生産性発現というのは衆議院生民代さんがある雑誌に高校さ
ロンドンの中で同性カップルというのは子供を産まないので生産性
床には大変差別受けてであるバッシングを受けた
という問題です
この影響のといった2017年までのデータ塾頭300生き切って簡略出兵れちまって
いいなります
これだけのとそれが多いよろしくねあればちょっとわかりづらいんで
他の子と比べてみました
阿部市辺野古で比べてみます
明る線が系の子です
会の構成の約愛191,000
le bt が辺野古を超えたのは生産性発現の時だけです
もちろんツイートの数だけで世間のかの新聞などを図ることはできないんですけれども
もしかしたら lgb 系トヨタは必ず相撲
皆さんがとっても関心があるというのではないな感じん
出動する ngd pr へ
発動しない高齢者であれ共通しているのは白血し傷つけられたくないという思いだと
思う
保存専門家のペーパーでは3時間に封じ社外ぬ人ほど石炭の低いというデータもあり
ます
まあそうやはり集お友達になること
して運用に一つの型にはめて考える
大事なんだと思う
私自身まだすこう智子の途中
友達女房怒って正解のマニュアルもなん
それと同じように彼らと友達になること彼らを主こそにも焼かれ正解はないんだと思う
そして私が最低特にを添えているのもめんどくさいということです
理解しなきゃいけないのは分かってると思うん
地雷多そうなテーマだから去らぬんや家
絶対っていうようなそういう雰囲気を感じることがいい
アメリー bt 団体の人は放射空虚
こういう風に言ってみました
私たちは普通の存在になりたいと思って活動しているのに
さんのほうがいい
っていう波動の存在になってしまう
を持ち戦法で自分もそれを怖いと思っている
なお決して彼は綱引と言われません
何としてあげ待ってよっ
人ではありません
自分のアリウムを丹念に強制されて苦しい思いをすることは皆様目立ってあることで
残念な村社会のあちこちにそういうことがあります
たぶん皆さんもこれからいくつも経験していると思います
女性が就活
最初に入っているあかもしれん
病気のそうだもん
生きづらさというものを考えることくさいっ
その時に雨組の[ __ ]以下の我慢して0
と言われていいのかどうか
もただのお互い様選んだと思う
私が生きやすい社会は多分あなたもいってやつ
あなたがいいて予定者から多分私の意見ですよ
そういう社会になることを願っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]